bonjour et bienvenue dans ce team hague
habitants collectivités entreprises et
en commun d'agir en faveur de l'éco
responsabilité
il montre l'exemple mais au fait c'est
quoi être éco responsable pour le savoir
nous sommes rendus à l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines être éco
responsable c'est finalement adapter son
comportement de manière à limiter
l'impact de ses activités sur
l'environnement dans notre vie de tous
les jours dans notre quotidien
nous nous déplaçons nous chauffons nous
mangeons nous faisons des achats dans
toutes ses activités et bien où il ya
des conséquences au niveau de
l'environnement et sociétal également et
être éco-responsable ça passe aussi par
la maîtrise de sa consommation
énergétique
ça tombe bien la lèque est aussi là pour
conseiller les particuliers les
professionnels ou les collectivités afin
de maîtriser au mieux leur consommation
énergétique tous les ans elle propose
ainsi à des familles saint-quentinoise
de passer l'hiver en éco responsabilité
à la faveur du défi familles à énergie
positive volontaire l'an passé charles
renard n'y a trouvé que des avantages et
a conservé de bonnes habitudes
ça c'est ce que j'utilise on me pour
m'échauffer sont des petits granulés de
bois ce point là davantage en fait de
pouvoir chauffer donc la thèse
principale
donc là on voit bien là la flamme ici
mais en fait je suis aussi donc équipé
avec un chauffage central c'est à dire
que donc il chauffe de l'eau qui donc
diffusée dans toute la maison
donc ça c'est pas forcément un système
on va dire qu'il est plus économe qu'un
autre c'est juste que là on a de
l'énergie
qui est donc renouvelables qui est du
bois qui donc n'est pas issu d'énergies
fossiles
j'ai participé l'année dernière au défi
famille l'énergie et moi j'étais
intéressé par faire des économies
d'énergie en fait pour vraiment un peu
un peu réduire la facture sans avoir
besoin de faire de gros travaux en fait
désolation autre chose comme ça la
moyenne de tous les participants c'est
autour de 8% et nous on a réussi à
atteindre
presque 30 % d'économie ça des pensions
sur les postes ce soit donc de chauffage
mais aussi d'électricité il ya plein de
petits gestes auxquels on pense pas mais
qui marchent en fait très bien ont déjà
c'est d'essayer d'éteindre toutes les
lumières quand on est quand on n'est pas
dans la pièce ça ça fait déjà des
sérieuses économies après on peut aussi
s'équiper en lampes basse consommation
des givrés aussi c'est son réfrigérateur
à son collaborateur au moins une à deux
fois par an j'ai installé des
interrupteurs sur à peu près tous les
équipements de la maison j'ai installé
aussi des programmateurs par exemple
comme la boxe pour le pour internet en
fait je l'éteins de minuit à 7h du matin
ce qui me fait à peu près un tiers de
consommation électrique de moi sur une
box alors ce qui est bien c'est que dans
le défi nous donne une boîte avec lequel
on peut mesurer tout on peut mesurer les
consommations instantanée de tous nos
équipements électriques
les débits d'eau dois je vais vous
montrer enfin on a vraiment un débit qui
est toujours intéressant soit
effectivement là c'est de l'eau mélangée
avec de l'air avant d'installer les
échos mousseux on était trois à neuf
litres d'eau par minute sur la plupart
des robinets de la maison est en fête
avec les échos mousseurs où il est tombé
à 4 5 et 6 comme la famille renard vous
souhaitez nourrir votre fibre
écocitoyenne des associations locales
peuvent vous y aider en janvier 2013 ce
qui en transition ainsi lancé à 50 ans
divine
le projet incroyable comestible pour
l'alimentation locale avec des fruits et
légumes bio est gratuit pour tout le
monde si si si possible d'un mouvement
qui vient plutôt des pays anglo saxons
ici ça se manifeste par des jardinières
de la commune qu'ont qui nous ont mis à
disposition nous à l'association et donc
les gens avec une petite affichette
savent qu'ils peuvent se servir
entretenir et se servir et puis après
c'est l'idée de cuisine ensemble de
manger ensemble
voilà c'est tout ça la mairie ne
plantait plus et jardinières parce qu
elles étaient dégradées et depuis qu'on
plante des légumes et qu'on a cette
petite affichette elles sont préservés
respecter et du coup la commune
massa lui a rien coûté et au contraire
ça valorise son cadre de vie aussi et de
fil en aiguille le centre social nous a
contactés pour dépasser juste le stade
de ses jardinières et maintenant avec
les habitants sur le quartier qui est
derrière nous l'idée de faire des mini
potager au pied des immeubles dans les
mois qui viennent on va refaire des
athlètes semis de bouturage 2
et on va planter ses jardinières et
aussi de nouveau potager donc donc des
plates-bandes en herbe
on va les transformer en mini potager
avec les habitants alors du coup ces
projets effectivement il a essaimé
puisqu'il ya des projets à la verrière à
montigny qui se sont mis en place avec
soin une école soit les services de la
commune sur des nouveaux bacs ont été
créées spécialement pour ça et si donc
depuis deux ans on a maintenant 11
jardinières mise à disposition par la
commune et on a sept projets de mini
potager dans le quartier qui est
derrière nous c'est clairement pas le
moment le vous ses plus beaux à voir
parce que ça c'est les plantes qu'on a
semé l'année dernière qu'on résiste à
l'hiver qui sont plutôt des vivaces ou
des petits arbustes mais effectivement
dans les mois qui viennent on va tenter
des courges des tomates c'est ça voilà
au mois de mai juin ça sera beaucoup
plus jolie plutôt dynamique que
l'association est aussi à l'origine d'un
verger dans ma ville qui a permis de
planter près de 200 arbres dans la
plupart des communes de saint quentin en
yvelines et dans les communes
limitrophes comme eising nous dégager
dans ma ville c'est cédric propres de
foot et pour les habitants et que on
peut planter les réfugiés un peu partout
dans les îles ces mauvaises de ville de
ville devienne l'hymne berger en 30 ans
dans les écoles dans l'espace public
sous 3 go et maintenant ça fait
tellement qu'on a du mal aux côtes et
probablement au niveau des arbres depuis
2011 à ce qu'ils sont
en quatre vingt dix arbres nous avons
commencé à mains nues et maintenant nous
avons planté pratiquement tous les
écoles maternelles et primaires avec mon
arbre fruitier à l'école c'est un projet
on continue on vient en france avec les
enfants des enfants qui pour le petit
verger
après avoir pu un peu mieux cerisier les
petits fruits pour les tout petits en
régie dans ma ville c'est devenu un
projet avec france internationale ont
été cités dans un an et un des livres
pour les lecteurs de vivre transition
justement comme l'exemple j'ai commandé
des habitants peut changer le monde peut
changer de mode oui vive et ça prend une
telle ampleur que les hôteliers donne
envie aux filles aussi de faire la même
chose au canada la belgique la suisse et
on a un jumelage avec comme but en
écosse alors bientôt tous éco
responsable c'est ce qu'espère en tout
cas monsieur madame brisson lauréats du
concours de la maison économe 2013 pour
les travaux effectués dans leur mise
parce qu'ils nous avaient motivé c'est
la recherche dans un premier temps d'un
meilleur confort
nous on a commencé déjà parents ont
changé donc tout ce qu'ils étaient tous
les ouvrants c'est à dire
les fenêtres les volets
pour rentrer avec double vitrage
meilleure isolation leur haut niveau de
la toiture ça c'est une deuxième plan
c'est donc les panneaux photovoltaïques
on ne produit pas pour nous parce
qu'aujourd'hui comment c'est pas
possible quand on est dans le cadre
d'une rénovation
donc on produit pour erdf pour la 2500
kg et en euros ça fait à peu près mille
quatre cents euros à l'année donc on
vend pour 1400 euros de d'électricité on
a fait poser donc des pompes à chaleur
pour remplacer la nôtre chauffages
électriques alors là par contre on fait
une économie certaine en commet en terme
d'électricité et on a un confrère de
chauffe alors là qui n'est pas
comparable est ce qu'on avait avant
parallèlement aux pompes à chaleur on a
fait installer aussi
un chauffe-eau thermodynamique on avait
donc une fosse septique
donc on avait la possibilité soit de
combler la fosse septique bon avec de la
terre du gravier tout ce qu'on voulait
soit la récupérer la ferme et why et
bien évidemment ce que nous avons fait
et donc on a donc une réponse à une
récupération de l'eau de pluie dans
cette ancienne fosse septique des
travaux utiles et bon pour la planète
mais qui est il faut le savoir un
certain coût et qui ne seront pas
d'amorties tout de suite entre les
pompes à chaleur et le ballon d'eau
chaude c'est un investissement grosso
modo 20000 euros donc vingt mille euros
compte tenu si vous voulez donc de
l'économie qui est fait je pense qu'on
peut avoir comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure un retour sur investissement
mais certainement pas avant 8 ans
concernant les panneaux photovoltaïques
je crois qu'on avait payé 20022 1000
pour les 24 m² et là je pense que le
retour sur investissement on peux pas
l'envisager avant dix ans en revendant
notre électricité 1400 euros
ça nous faisait face quasiment notre
facture de notre propre consommation que
nous payons à leur des suites comme mais
parce qu'il faut bien sortir de chez soi
elles seront au travail là encore des
solutions existent pour se déplacer de
manière éco-responsable oui oui il y
aller covoiturage bien sûr ou encore les
circulations douces des modes de
déplacement soutenue par la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la casse qui
qui s'est engagé dès 2008 aux côtés des
acteurs économiques pour mettre en place
quatre plans de déplacement
inter-entreprises d'épée des yeux une
quarantaine d'entreprises du territoire
sont aujourd'hui fédérer pour favoriser
ses déplacements à l'image du crédit
agricole bonjour aux jacques beaume
alors dites nous tout c'est aujourd'hui
participer
aux différentes actions du plan de
déplacement inter entreprises mises en
place par la caisse qui pour faciliter
ou trouver des solutions pour faciliter
les déplacements de nos collaborateurs
c'est vrai que nous avions l'habitude de
prendre très souvent notre voiture ou
les transports en commun effectué
aujourd'hui il faut trouver des
solutions alternatives des solutions on
va dire des déplacements doux des moyens
de transports doux c'est dans ce cadre
là que nous essayons avec les
partenaires ou les entreprises du
territoire de trouver des solutions
adaptées et nous sommes présents de peu
plus de trente ans mais aujourd'hui
depuis un an nous sommes en train de
transformer notre campus de saint
quentin en yvelines et elle était 2016
nous serons 5000 donc il faut trouver
des solutions
une des solutions s'élever loïc dans un
projet de transformation du campus on a
cette offre qui correspond à quelque
chose d'innovant quelque chose de
moderne
on a mis en place pour deux raisons
essentielles le côté éco responsable et
2e aussi sur l'autopartage
c'est une solution d'autopartage de dire
que les vélos en une fois de 10
aujourd'hui malécot l'orateur se le
partagent
je vois au bout de on a mis en place en
juin
2014 quasiment neuf mois après que 1 pb
c'est sur cette solution
ici je demain on enlevait 7 cette
proposition pour les collaborateurs
je pense que les correcteurs on dirait
on revient en arrière quand s'était mis
en place je trouve ça vraiment génial
parce que ça permet moi qui ne vient pas
en voiture ici de pouvoir aller plus
rapidement soit au centre commercial
comme une petite course à faire ou alors
à la piscine de saint cyr j'utilise une
fois par semaine au moins je fais du
vélo les jours pour aller à la gare et
je trouve que pour l'environnement
pas de besoin de polluer on va aussi
vite et en voiture que si on pour
trouver une place de parking c'est
toujours très compliqué donc c'est
vraiment pratique et bon l'hiver où
j'utilise vais peut-être un peu moins
mais j'utilise quand même l été c
c'est parfait parce que saint quentin et
bien équipé aussi en termes de voies
cyclables on s'y prenant et c'est tout
le système de réservation fait que j'ai
toujours réussi à voir avec aujourd'hui
il faut savoir que nous l'utilisons nous
proposons l'utilisation de ces vélos
électriques sur une plage méridienne
c'est entre 11h30 et 15h nous sommes en
train de réfléchir avec la drh du groupe
pour pouvoir l'étendre sur toute la
journée pour pouvoir aller de mon
domicile à mon entreprise
les demandes d'entreprises à mon
domicile nous avons d'autres projets sur
l'autopartage sur des développements de
transport plus alternatifs tels que la
voiture
donc nous nous engageons dans cette
danseuse dans cette voie ainsi se
termine ce numéro de ski mag consacré à
l'éco responsabilité je vous donne
rendez vous le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle émission consacrée à de jeunes
talents qui ne vous laisseront pas
indifférent ici la portez vous bien